Very cool. Alright, here's how my verify algorithm works.
First, I make sure that we have a mapping
from all of the nodes of the graph to--
Hmm, I didn't check everything-- Well here's what I checked
Make sure that the number of nodes in the coloring
matches the number of nodes in the graph.
If not, then this is not a good coloring.
Then for each node in the coloring list,
well, if it's the case that the coloring for the node
is not a valid color, then we say that's bad
and then we check all of the neighbors of the node,
and we check for each combination of node and its neighbor,
whether the colorings match, and if any of the
colorings match, that's bad, because that means
two adjacent regions with the same color,
so we return false.
And if we survive all of those tests,
then at the end of the day we return 'true'.
The thing that I didn't check for that I probably
should have checked for, is to make sure that
the nodes that are in use in the certificate,
are the same as the nodes that in use in the graph.
That would be kind of weird.
Or, if it has nodes that aren't in the graph,
then this will actually crash, which is not good,
so I probably should have checked for that.
But the essence of it is just this:
We're running through all of the edges in the graph,
and making sure that the colors don't match.